not sure if apple's in the st patrick's  day or not but i guess they may be they  released green iphones in march  alpine green for the i 13 pro and pro  max and green for the mini how about  that beautiful right not too bad  actually in bright daylight they look a  lot better in person than in images my  personal preference though is the alpine  green because i like the frosted glass  but if you want a more pronounced green  you really like green  go mini or go for the 13. you're going  to enjoy it anyway we got a full review  of the iphone 13 coming up with gaming  involved so stay tuned for that without  take care stay safe and we'll see you  very soon  in green